Khloe Kardashian and Tristan Thompson  are getting serious it's a miracle  doors closed - Chloe tells et she and  her NBA pro beau are quote madly in love  and things are getting much more serious  between the two saying she is the  happiest she has been in a really long  time she feels really strong about this  relationship and future with Tristan he  adores her I just go with how I feel the  couple is clearly feeling the love in  their relationship and have been going  strong for months now the source tells  us khlomoney is the happiest she has  been in a really long time and adds the  32 year old reality star is really  supportive of Tristan since becoming a  father to son Prince last month do you  think Chloe and her new man are in it  for the long haul let us know over on  Twitter at ET now  [Music]